besides flat bellies are unhealthy our
organs need space to work properly and
fat gives that space
[Music]
what do you mean they need space i've
seen a ton of bad medical takes on
twitter but sam here has compiled a full
list for me to pop my blood vessels over
huge thanks audible for sponsoring this
video
if you were almost healthy you'd like
how your pee tastes if you were actually
healthy you wouldn't be peeing at all
bro my head is like level 10 about to
explode first of all what is almost
healthy and no you shouldn't like how
your p taste that is not something that
is ideal here for any reason whatsoever
if you're not peeing at all that is not
healthy that means there's something
going on dehydration kidney failure or
something else happening where do i even
begin
yeah did my guy draw see someone could
be judging this unfairly they might
think this is a
the he no
no they thought their arm had a ribcage
they're just a humorous ulna radius cold
showers resets your vitals if it resets
your vibra
that's basically a defibrillator that's
a problem imagine every time you hop in
the shower and you accidentally had it
cold you just like shock
yourself even those that are suffering
hypertension are advised to take cold
showers great medication intelligent use
of water can eliminate eighty percent of
all lifestyle diseases i dare say all
you dare say because imagine you came
into my office and in 80 of cases i just
told you to go and take a cold shower
you'd not be very happy with me in fact
you wouldn't even pay for my services
they just have like showers in the
emergency room a few years ago a guy
i've known for years a marathon runner
told me he couldn't get lyme disease
when running through the woods because
he ran too fast it takes to bite up all
it takes is for one of the ticks to grab
onto your clothes and then later in the
day start leeching on and feeding
according to tick-tock rings will leave
a dark line if you have anemia
what okay you're anemic
if you have low hemoglobin low
hematocrit low iron not if your jewelry
is cheap myth you should drink a glass
of juice in the morning fact you
shouldn't drink it on an empty stomach
because the acid acts aggressively
i love that this page is called rhinos
gaze
do they look at rhinos and what they do
and they're like oh we got to make this
happen i don't even know what this
advice is but drink a glass of water in
the morning
it's important you can absorb the
vitamin d for midday sun like 12 to 2
generally kind of misinformation because
you don't actually absorb the vitamin
your body with the uv rays can transform
the vitamin within you to be a usable
form because it's not like you're like
photosynthesis
actually i guess it's kind of like
photosynthesis sugar keeps your energy
up and your appetite down nibble on a
cookie an hour before lunch is this no
no i was about to lose my mind on this
but i'm 90 sure that this is fake it
looks so photoshopped that i refuse to
give it any of my energy right now 96
total that's almost everybody but get
your clicks wait whoa
cdc says only 31 percent of men and 65
percent of women wash their hands after
using the restroom
oh
yeah you don't add up to percentages
together but yeah a lot of people don't
wash their hands after the restroom my
charitable thinking is that they're
using hand sanitizer but i don't think
that holds true for everybody back to
the tweets in just a second but first i
want to thank audible for sponsoring
this video last week i was lucky enough
to interview lori gottlieb about her
book maybe you should talk to someone
found this book on audible and was so
into it i just had to have her on the
channel to dive in deeper we discussed
all things mental health including our
own experiences going to therapy make
sure to go watch that interview after
this video and sign up for audible today
by going to audible.com dr mike or
texting dr mike to the number 500 500.
remember though doctor is spelled out
and you'll begin your free 30-day trial
with that you'll have access to
audible's premium selection and audible
plus catalog giving you access to the
latest bestsellers guided meditations
podcasts and so much more the link to
sign up is down below and the end card
after this video will take you straight
to my interview with lori gottlieb all
right let's get back to these tweets
veganism makes you age faster because
your cells are mostly made up of fat and
protein the two things vegans don't eat
well they don't eat animal fat they
could still eat fat coconut oil has a
ton of fat and protein there's a ton of
protein that vegans eat beans i love
beans black beans
so good so rich
why are you running do you compete in
some sort of running event if not stop
running it can't even be regarded as
exercise running is a very unhealthy
catabolic and destructive physical
activity no
if this person really thought to
themselves at what rate we have obesity
in this country and how it's detrimental
to human health that if we can even get
a small percentage of people to run and
exercise how many lives would be
improved and saved they would probably
delete this tweet that's my charitable
thing new zealand is making period
products free in all schools all this is
going to do is encourage girls to have
their periods at school i don't think
this is a good idea i hope that's a sick
joke because you don't decide when you
have your period this person must not
know much about female anatomy happy
valentine's day i'm swearing off men i'm
vaccinated if that's a concern and i
heard the vaccine can be sexually
transmitted like i could pass it on
if you get that on a dating app you
should panic and on a dating app you
probably want to know what types of
vaccine that person received like did
they just get a coveted vaccine or do
they also get an hpv vaccine because
that matters too and actually prevents
cancers that's right it prevents hpv
which is one of the leading causes of
cervical cancer and preventable cases of
cervical cancer acne should not be
normalized it is a reflection of error
and diet and or lifestyle terrible
medical take terrible terrible terrible
a huge percentage of acne has nothing to
do with lifestyle habits it has a lot to
do with genetic factors hormonal factors
things essentially outside of your
control so please don't blame people
when they have acne as if it was a
choice elon musk adderall is an anger
amplifier a void at all costs i hate
statements like this even if you're an
individual who thinks that we are over
prescribing medications like adderall
which is a medication used for adhd as
an example you don't voice it like this
this lacks nuance elon imagine your
child who truly needs and benefits from
adderall and as a result you are now
deathly afraid to take it because you're
a fan of elon musk way to go bro please
reconsider saying you're burnt or you
must burn easily that is an unhelpful
invocation that can make an unconscious
mind feel vulnerable and fearful of the
sun this is not a burn this is light
nutrition i haven't had one unpleasant
sensation for my skin because i don't
wish to separate from it i welcome this
color what you have uv radiation burn on
your skin in fact if you stayed out a
little bit longer what may happen is
you'd form blisters very painful
blisters anyone who's had a sunburn will
tell you that having even a few of these
throughout your lifetime increases your
risk for serious skin cancer your
daughter has diabetes and it's
incredibly likely that you are at fault
be a better parent and provide your
child with a healthy diet um hold on one
second there are two types of diabetes
out there type 2 diabetic largely
occurring later in life potentially as a
result of a specific type of diet but
type 1 diabetic is an autoimmune
condition that you have little to no
control over its development what are
you talking about if a child is born
with an autoimmune condition where the
immune system attacks it's insulin
releasing cells how is that the child's
fault or the parent's fault or anyone's
fault for that matter if you can find a
blood doctor he can help you clean your
blood it may take up to six months but
well worth it i know man who's doing
right now okay a blood doctor is a
hematologist and i promise you
hematologists aren't going around
cleaning blood the only way that you can
really clean your blood is to do like
dialysis if you're going through
dialysis that means your kidneys have
failed and that could also make sense if
you're following some kind of weird
unhealthy health regimen germs do not
cause disease
is that a hill you want to die like i'm
just curious are you gonna say germs
don't cause disease but germs causing
some kind of dysfunction in your body
lead to disease like
no germs cause disease but at the same
time there are some germs that can help
our bodies that are symbiotic with our
bodies that we need to function well
that we use to derive nutrients from
certain foods so not all germs cause
disease is a fair statement but do not
cause disease is misinformation actually
smoking is pretty healthy the tar come
on bro this is a joke it says the tar
coats your lungs and serves as a shield
against real pollutants like asbestos
bro real pollutants did you ever see the
ingredients list of what's in a
cigarette check this out muscle
generated from plants as opposed to lean
meat will be lost much faster bro
show me a study and not something that
you just said while you were eating food
hiv does not cause aids biggest cause of
aids is malnutrition then substance
abuse would burn out lifestyle what is
what happens on twitter check out my
interview with psychotherapist and
best-selling author lori gottlieb right
here super interesting conversation i
really enjoyed it i know you will too as
always stay happy and healthy